this movie is definitely about guns and
surfing I know that much this credit
here is for being married to the
director hi
John in Utah early versions of the
script had this character named Michael
Michigan Danny Texas and Andrew North
Dakota know nothing in fact you know
less than nothing Jon Snow you're real
blue flames special aren't you son young
dumb and full it was a blue flame
special and how does this relate to the
amount of semen and math skills one has
I've been in the field for 22 years I've
fired my piece over 19 times in the line
of duty cameras catch Gary Busey saying
all the normally says to anyone who will
listen ex-presidents robbery gang is
extremely biased against all things
Gerald Ford if you're a clearly
professional bank robbing outfit and
you've evaded capture for so many years
why would you give detectives anything
to work on which this is clearly going
to allow them to use 27 banks in two
years sounds like some truly law
enforcement if you ask me they vanish
like a virgin on prom night we made that
chips I just realized that the dialogue
of this movie supplied half the world's
watch list with their own personal
catchphrases any time you do a finished
jerking off watching MTV those cops
disrespect those other cops cliche man
LA has changed a lot during that time
there got dirtiness X got clean what the
actual is this a period piece is this
pre 1981 before AIDS
also if you look at the screenwriters
picture on the IMDB that explains it
well maybe I can do better than some
over the hill burnout Keanu Reeves
performance in this movie accidentally
inspires the birth of Paul Walker and
the movie itself inspired The Fast and
the Furious so it was only a matter of
time before those two got together yeah
mad mad yeah what do you want to do
about it
Jonnie BC cops drinking beer on the job
hope you two will drink Corona they're
traveling on the money going where the
waves are why has this asshole Pappas
never once looked into the surfing
community for these robbers if he's
looked for them for so long he found all
sorts of evidence and sat on it I guess
waiting perky on you to show up discount
future panic room Kristen Stewart well
can I just walk around with this thing
under my arm an axe stone ask a few
questions isn't that typically directing
style anyway how hard can it be surfing
really super incredibly difficulty hard
the names Johnny Utah Oh she heard that
also how is this undercover operation
ever supposed to succeed if he's using
his real name and now for your viewing
enjoyment the female surfer will
stealthily undress while the undercover
cop watches her I'm not sure when we
needed to see this but I got some great
tips on how to change without exposing
my privates Johnny Utah makes his move
on Tank Girl the same spot where Brian
O'Connor and Dominic Toretto bonded over
shrimp I mean what do you want why do
you keep hanging around here he just got
here
a shrimper fries to go Wow obvious stay
away from me bob is obvious and yet
Johnny will ignore it because in the
movies the protagonist can't be a
stalker he can only be right football
scholarship
5 it is gonna take a really long time
Tyler would be amazing it's cinemasins
so Tyler agrees to give surfing lessons
to someone who's obviously stalking her
also man this girl must have really been
jonesing for someone to teach surfing
too because she's like all in on day one
and two minutes of surfing lessons I
mean couldn't the movie you've just
started here that's Bodhi
they call him the bud is that fun is
that the new cooler shaker song also
Utah doesn't ask what the hell that
means because quite frankly he's still
trying to figure out what the other
words meant
it's a surfboard alright Jonny stumbles
on the whole gang of thieves after a day
of surf training and maybe it's supposed
to be two weeks for all I know but in
that case I'm still sending the
convenience that Tyler and Bodhi know
each other out of all the surfers in LA
this is the guy Utah's looking for good
catch and that's all it takes to
undercover cop your way into this gang
yeah
but the number of vehicles with their
lights on requirement for this night
Beach football game movie
unintentionally inspires the
replacements
Utah gets hit by several blocks while
Bodhi runs full speed and still catches
up to it taking sports too seriously
don't you know who this is first off why
would he but second off why doesn't he
wouldn't there have been a small
introduction before playing this game
Johnny Utah we were gonna kick his ass
but because he's a pseudo celebrity from
three years ago playing football for
Ohio State
I guess he's okay also these surfers
remember Johnny Utah's college football
days which is awesome for helping him
get into this gang but I'm still hung up
on the fact that he's using his real
name on an undercover assignment there's
virtually no reason for Johnny's balls
to be pissed off right now other than
that cop movies from this era always
needed to have a boss who threatens to
kick the hero off the case after every
scene harp
undercover it takes time yeah when were
also working undercover since when
what have you been doing over the last
two weeks you two have produced exactly
squat these guys have been robbing banks
for a couple of summers now and the
evidence gathered from those
investigations didn't produce anything
and I'm pretty sure it didn't lead all
this yelling
anyway what's this problem we're
handling our caseload I'm surfing on my
own time Johnny basically proves that
John C McKinley's character is only in
this movie to satisfy what the audience
expects out of a cop movie twenty-eight
robberies and what do we get from it
after all these robberies why doesn't
the FBI have an agent around nearly
every bank in the city or at least have
a couple guys driving around several
target areas and surfers are territorial
they stick mostly to certain breaks
they're going to find these guys based
on going around to several beaches and
plucking hair samples from tons of
random surfers based on the idea that
they apparently mostly surf certain
breaks that's pretty convenient
latigo beach nice Point Break roll
credits discount Anthony kita holy Sh
only in movies made in the 90s or
earlier can people get punched 52
goddamn times and show very little
effective said beating also Bodhi ex
machina they only live to get radical I
don't have any real understanding of the
sea so they'll never get the spiritual
side of it it's that place where you
lose yourself and you find yourself
that's deep really you could describe
just about anything you enjoy doing and
take seriously world's least conspicuous
stakeout shift change ever sported this
is a bully this this movie sets up these
guys to be assholes but they are
absolutely totally 100% right
Eadie's party taking place in the early
90s has decidedly 70s soundtrack watch
yourself she's a wild aka I'm already 50
years storm what's that that's kind of a
legend no it's real it's absolutely real
I'm having so much fun at this drunken
surfer campfire I almost didn't even
notice the wall of exposition smacking
me in the face I'm a little stealth
mission you up for it this is the only
time in movie history I can think of
that is actually a parody of itself look
a bunch of headlights shining toward the
water isn't going to make the freakin
water visible and are these guys always
changing out car batteries because of
their nighttime Beach activities this
looks cool on film but totally drenches
your arm in lighter fluid and even if
you're going to be far enough away when
it lights your arm still smelling like
lighter fluid for the rest of the night
Dawg you don't need to see Bodie is like
the obi-wan Kenobi of surfing how does a
cop go from cop to surfer that can hang
on the gnarliest of waves at night with
the God of all human surfers within like
weeks I kind of feel like this romance
is both I love how none of his newfound
surfer friends bothered to make sure he
woke up before the beat cops started
walking the beach way too long post
coital morning kiss somehow even though
Utah was already super late and spent
three days kissing Tyler he was able to
show up to the raid before it started
anyway even as strictly backup it's
amazing how stupid the cops are
including undercover Keanu in any way
whatsoever in this rate way to be
stealth asshole first that this cop just
pops his face up into the window like
this second that this asshole inside
doesn't notice it at all also pouring
beer on Cheerios makes them be Rios just
FYI movie saves money by simply filming
an average everyday morning for Anthony
Kiedis yet angelo out of there pulling
out of an arsenal once again a simple
radio transmission can't be heard
because either the radio doesn't work or
somebody's moving along and does this
grass even need mowing it looks perfect
already speak into the microphone squid
brain it's almost like the writers of
the original Batman series join forces
with the writers of die hard 2 and Jimmy
Buffett to finish the script hero looks
in a fractured mirror cliche especially
in Utah I'd like you to meet agent Dietz
where's the DEA he was working deep
cover and the used law enforcement
agencies not cross-checked with each
other before conducting raids so that
this doesn't happen if they don't I'm
sending real life here the shot is
supposed to be telling me about his
continued relationship with the girl and
his own personal struggle to sleep due
to his professional cups but all I can
think about is how 90s the nightstand
contents are I'm wondering an hour
the picture is all this surfing footage
going to lead to Johnny Utah finding out
they're the bad guys
moon surfing you look like you saw a
ghost forget about it kid they're ghosts
- basically unrelated comments that have
very little to do with actual evidence
lead Johnny Utah to a dr. house moment
about these surfers also is Johnny just
now realizing Bodhi and friends might be
the heist masters he's looking for
really seriously blinded by kindness
this dude was Tia's lunch Patrick's
Roadhouse har-har movie inside joke is
not hilarious so does Johnny Utah make
an appearance at his own Private Idaho
later actually he does a few months
later as it turns out meatballs 1 to 9
weeks yep these are the kind of clueless
motherfuckers the FBI sends out on
undercover assignments they like their
narcos stupidest posts ha ha ha ha this
guy is still laughing at the comics
while Johnny get some meatball
sandwiches I'm beginning to think that
harp guy is right about these two
assholes they actually aren't very good
at their jobs Johnny runs at these fools
despite him also being undercover with
these fools which means they now know
he's a cop which makes me wonder why
johnny was even on this stakeout to
begin with Johnny Utah has stalked
reporing longest parking garage ever
lost between cars for a quick getaway
it's a good idea to not only torch the
original getaway car but also another
random car at a gas station and to take
way too long doing it so the cops can
catch up in the movie can keep happening
Johnny Utah comes in to save the day and
completely blows as already should be
blown cover instead of shooting the way
as Keanu learns to do by the time speed
rolls around Johnny Utah just runs after
this fool I guess for exercise this foot
chase is almost as riveting as dirt dog
tossing what is it about 90s movies and
staging action sequences in the concrete
le river Johnny finally encounters
gravity and realism except his leg
leading to the end of the chase that
should probably have ended miles ago but
whatever the 90s friendship anchor
bullets what's the other guy look like
Johnny goes home and immediately phones
up the buddy from his undercover surfer
bro assignment which I guess makes sense
from the Dick's perspective but from the
criminals just ID'd me during that Chase
perspective does not make sense at all
it's not a girl who was just demanding
answers suddenly switches gears and
craves only kisses because the movie is
ready to move on I guess this was never
about money for us it was about us
against the system that system that
kills the human spirit if that's true
then why not give the money to charity
or something and is the system supposed
to learn a lesson about the human spirit
from all this also I guess Point Break
was kind of the matrix of its day
Bodhi is Morpheus pulling Keanu Reeves
out of his boring job and showing him
the truth about the system so you trust
me after
that insane speech yes when attempting
to still kill someone at night it's best
to ensure you in your gun shadow are
extra huge on the wall just for
symbolism did your parents die in a car
accident because that is the be-all
end-all fact of facts I've decided to
build my reality apart so I needed you
at first but after I did you I agree
with the lady I wanted to tell you but I
couldn't I was afraid you'd leave
keanu the actor ladies and gentlemen I
want you to know that I've never known
anyone like you before in my life even
though I barely know you and I could you
like twice Johnny is somehow stupid
enough to believe that maybe it's
possible Bodie and his gang didn't ID
him during yesterday's big chase
sequence Donnie
jump out of a perfectly good Cody senses
that Utah's not cut out for FBI work
that he's just an adrenaline junkie like
him but this guy gets no instructions on
how to jump out of an airplane or when
to use his parachute or anything forty
seconds of accidentally inspiring
terminal velocity how does he know what
to do how does he know how to move his
body in order to join the circle I feel
like we missed the part where you talk
talked about his service in the army
just our ex-president robbery gang
predicts future Keanu Reeves movie yeah
he's dead you can't pull your chute that
late and not have serious damage just
from terminal velocity press play
hey I just took you on a skydiving trip
that was amazing oh and by the way i
kidnapped your girlfriend what was the
point of all that probably just to have
a skydiving scene why not here's another
movie where the hero is motivated to go
completely against his moral fiber
because a girl he flies is in trouble
you see that's why I need Rosie I could
never do that man I could never hold a
knife to tyler's throw geez a man named
Rosie a woman named Tyler and anyone
named Bodhi so hard to keep up with a
star I am an FBI agent dick go to the
vault Bodhi changes the whole protocol
for robbing the banks just so he can
teach Utah a lesson or something
something system human spirit just
doesn't make sense for his character
whatsoever look if they were prone to
making more and more daring bank jobs
this would make sense but doing the same
robbery over and over for the express
reason to not get caught only to change
it now
ludicrous why we go to the boat we never
go to the vault and he didn't even tell
his buddies they were doing that either
why would you take off your mask
keanu had a bulletproof vest fYI you
didn't know that what's wrong with you
haven't you ever seen a 90s movie this
guy's death scene acting you deserve
each other don't you I'm you just bad as
he is
other than the out-of-nowhere outburst
earlier harp is pretty much right
remember all this is possible because
Pappas sent Utah to go buy some meatball
sandwiches and he was laughing at the
comics in a newspaper like a
seven-year-old while Bodie and his crew
did another bank job
in front of them well that is a good
movie moment but isn't he fired now and
after that they let Pappas take Johnny
with no questions asked this movie takes
place in reality seriously one of the
crew just happens to be in a spot where
they lucked out behind Pappas what was
he doing talking with the ground crew
about how the LA Raiders will never move
back to Oakland dad is this movie
referencing itself or it's late 2015
remake this here is the worst shot since
grito was made to shoot first now that
he's bloody and dying Roach can now fire
dead center on Pappas twice Oh No Pappas
wasn't wearing a bulletproof vest this
is some Darwin's beard I'm not fun you
guys San Felipe men can find start dogs
in yes well you make a convincing
argument I didn't see it that way
let's go man bode for some reason wants
to bring Utah along instead of just
killing the final witness here and now
and getting the fuck out of Dodge after
waiting a good several seconds Johnny
jumps out after Bodhi then miraculously
is instantly right on his tail here's
yet another movie trying to make me
think you can survive while opening your
chute this late in line ass movie but I
knew you wouldn't miss a fifth to your
store Bodhi all that stuff earlier about
these guys being smart being ghosts when
they rob banks just kind of went out the
door did it hey I know I might be
getting chased by the FBI but those
killer waves in Australia man you gotta
go down across the line and people trust
you they die it's amazing after Kenneth
Branagh saw any of Kiana's work during
this period he said kion it would make a
great Don John it much ado about nothing
how does this happen
how is Utah allowed back in the good
graces of the cops to go after Bodie but
not allowed to bring backup
and a helicopter shows up in a minute so
don't tell me he's out here on his own
the plan was apparently okay Utah you go
in alone and we'll send a helicopter in
five minutes hopefully by then you cuff
yourself to the suspect if not I mean I
don't know one weighs my whole life has
been about this moment Johnny well
except for the 30 banks you robbed
because of the system but I get your
point
Johnny Utah lets Bodhi out of the cops
to ride a once-in-a-lifetime wave
because movie Bodhi apparently dies
Johnny walks off without caring and
quits being a cop
and scene sure he quits the force
because he's going to be fired anyway
but he's also probably brought up on
charges right I mean I will if they
won't
may I ask why you felt little Tiffany
deserve to die
don't any idea why you're stealing from
your new friends are dead
karmak how's it beeping Tommy that's a
big thing
got me Tommy Tommy Tommy
think about it like the first time he
got laid he's gotta go
daddy are you sure this is right
afraid to step
moving the balls
my life a quarter mile at a time
hey Gotham a better place hmm that's
down eyes down we're here for the bank's
money not your money your money is
insured by the federal government you're
not gonna lose a dime I headed over to
Australian the Hawaiian internationals
me MEC are gonna wing on over the London
jam with the stones